hey there and welcome to the motion
science video podcasts my name is
Cameron and today we're going to talk
about something I get asked all the time
people cost I asked me how do you come
up with ideas or how do you figure out
what you're going to create there are so
many possibilities and the simple answer
is creative constraints
[Music]
hey there and welcome to the motion
science video podcast my name is Cameron
you know that and as I mentioned before
the titles there today we're talking
about something very important which is
creative constraints because like I said
I get asked all the time like how do I
come up with ideas how do I figure out
what it is I'm going to create for a
project because there's so many
possibilities when it comes to motion
graphics and that is true that is that
is very true there's a lot of
possibilities I feel like a lot of times
with motion graphics that it's it's
endless right there's every day every
week I'm seeing new techniques coming
out or people pushing a technique a
little bit farther and and it just opens
up my mind to a lot of like you know
potential ideas for projects and and
that's exactly the point of this is that
I'm seeing a technique that I recognize
the base of it and I'm saying wow look
how they pushed it in a different
direction or they pushed a little bit
farther than what I've seen in the past
and that's a purple of creative
constraints it's saying okay if I limit
myself to approaching a project this way
how can I make it even better and that's
how we get better work better projects
better motion design okay
essentially if you think about having
unlimited creativity that ultimately
creates unlimited problems right because
if we have just an open platform an open
source an open amount of possibilities
for where we can go with the project
that's gonna just create a lot of
problems because there's no direct path
there's no constraint saying okay you
have to work within this this realm of
of creativity to come up with a solution
so if a client well the thing about like
when a client comes to you okay when a
client comes to you they typically are
going to come to you with limited
creative they're not going to have an
unlimited color palette they're not
going to have
unlimited logos unlimited typefaces that
you know unlimited imagery to work with
because they have like a brand guide
typically or they have an idea of where
they want to go now if they don't have
that and they're like it's an open
canvas that's a client you probably
don't want okay but that's another topic
because that's not an ideal client
that's a client who doesn't know what
they want and they're gonna keep him
coming back to you over and over and
over again and it's gonna create a lot
of headache for you so you don't want
that client so but a good client is
gonna come to you and say okay number
one here's our load let's say we're
doing a logo animation here's our logo
these are the three colors that are in
our brand these are the three colors you
have to work with this is the one or two
typefaces that you have to work with
right and so you're already creatively
constrained to those five or six assets
to work with you know if you're working
with like let's say a title sequence the
title sequence is based on a movie
that's let's say it's an action movie so
you're already not gonna like approach
the title sequence from a romantic point
of view it's an action movie and it's
let's say it's a dark action movie which
of course you know I love dark so that's
gonna say we need to work with dark
textures and dark colors or I mean it
can go on and on and on a typical client
is gonna come to you with a limited
creative palette and that's how you need
to approach your own personal work okay
if you want to create art and you want
to actually finish that art then you
need to have constraints okay simplicity
plus the lack of options unleashes the
power of creativity let me say that
again simplicity plus the lack of
options unleashes the power creativity
this is an amazing exercise for any
artist and emotion designer my best work
comes from creative constraints creative
limitations
if I just actually just finished
recording a lesson for pro flows plus
its if you haven't heard of pro flows
plus it's a membership that I have
through motion science it's where it's
at it's where every month I release new
content to you new trainings on
techniques and workflows and I just
actually finished recording this morning
a lesson on on something that I don't
want to go into details about it but it
was a lesson that I really struggled
with I had a topic and the topic if you
think of a theme right like let's say
the theme is the color red or well let's
just say the color red right the theme
is red red is that's a lot that could be
the color red it could be a red wagon it
could be the color of death as red it
could be love right love is red it could
be you know I think of like for me
person I think of like the USSR right
propaganda things like that that could I
mean that red is it's too broad right so
I had this theme for this the set of
lessons I was creating and I had to take
that theme and I had I told myself all
right you've got three shapes to work
with for this theme and I want you to
take those three shapes how's this me
telling myself and create a really
powerful lesson because I you know
sometimes I'm really hard on myself when
I want to create lessons to teach you
guys because I want you guys I'm all
about a value right and I want to give
you as much value as possible for what
you're paying for and I want to take
your knowledge of motion design and push
it to that next level and so when I do
that I want to create these amazing
lessons for you and if I limit myself to
three objects which is what I did and I
say I have to make something super rad
super dope
- to show you how you can take three
objects and push it to something that
looks really dope that's what pushes me
creatively and I'm proud to say that I
did it and I feel really awesome about
it but before I limited myself to these
three objects I had that theme and I've
racked my brain on it for days I like to
typically take like when I'm teaching
lessons emotion science I like to take
several several days and think about
what I want to create around a theme and
I had done that with this theme but I
found that was test I do a lot of
testing and I built this project and I
built another project I build a third
prop I think I built four projects and
as tests and I'm like man these all suck
man they're not just you know I look
again I'm hard of myself maybe you guys
would have enjoyed what they were they
maybe look about another time but they
just they weren't there and so I forced
these creative constraints on myself I
said okay here's these three shapes
create a lesson and I did it and I'm
proud of what I create just gave me
chills sand that right I find that for
client work it's the same process my
clients come to me and they give me
brand guides and they give me assets to
work with and they're like here's the
generalized idea now create something
you know having a client brief is ideal
because a client brief it limits you
right it limits you on what you can do
have you guys checked out idea to
execution the series I have it's here on
YouTube it's also you can find it in
different places look on YouTube or
Instagram but in it I show you how to
take a creative brief I also teach this
in style craft how you take a creative
brief and you break it down those are
limitations in that creative brief and
that is what you have to work with and
when you have a set amount of assets to
work with that's when you say okay well
I have these things now what can I do
with them what can I create that's
amazing
because I don't want to put out anything
as a motion designer that that I'm not
proud of I'm not gonna put another's
work I've done
for clients that isn't most exciting
work there's corporate work I've done
over the years
it pays some of the bills yes we all do
it I guarantee you every those motion
designers that you see out there in the
world that are created the most amazing
work they all do work behind the scenes
that you never see because they pay the
bills right now that's going on on
another subtopic but just having those
constraints allows me to put out work
that I'm very very proud of and I find
that typically those constraints will
push me in ways I never thought possible
if you look at science like what
scientists do they scientists all the
time have these limitations their work
here's where we're at and we need to get
to here and how can we accomplish that
engineers do that inventors do that how
can we solve this problem when we only
have this to work with and that's that's
the same as create that's creative
constraints right so what I would advise
you to do is you need to limit your
assets if you're starting from scratch
and you I'm a big you know proponent of
doing spec work because spec work
creatively fulfills you it you put that
spec work out to the world and it
attracts the clients that you're looking
for and it's this this cycle right so
whenever you're setting out to create
something and you're like where do I
begin
well you start by you limit your assets
you let you limit what you have to work
with so maybe you set forth you say I'm
going to create you know a piece I'm
gonna use this typeface I'm gonna use
this image I'm going to use this color
palette I'm going to limit myself to
five seconds if I can get that out there
five seconds and I'm gonna use this
music track that's a lot of times how I
like to work I could base a lot of stuff
off of audio and there I've limited
myself to four or five assets and I can
begin I can start getting creative I
listen to that music and that music you
know inspires me to go a direction I
know I had these four
assets to work with this typeface to
work with what can I do interesting with
this typeface it's fun when you have an
ugly typeface a typeface that doesn't
necessarily resonate with you it's fun
to see where you can push that
creatively you also need to limit your
plugins okay
I preached this all the time now there's
a time and place for plugins right and I
talked about in other videos but you
need to limit your plugins from the
get-go unless you're doing something
very specific to a plug-in if you're
using a plug-in for a physical physics
you know there's like plugins like
Newton that can do physics or if you're
using particle systems inside of After
Effects you know there's particle system
plugins that's a specific type of job
otherwise limit your use of plugins till
the very end
that's the Polish that's what I always
like to keep at the very end so limit
your use of plugins limit your use of
effects in general which typically is
plugins and scripts but limit your use
of effects right and you also want to
limit your time that's a big big one
right limit your time there's a lot of
artists that I see that they they create
something and they come back to it and
they come back to it again and again and
again
and at the end it's it's a kind of a
turd right it doesn't look that great so
if you can limit your time to a project
that's pointy it's a great creative
constraint to really help you create
something awesome like you know dailies
there's a lot of people are a lot of
artists out there doing dailies I mean
that limits you right you may have two
or three hours to create something every
single day that's a creative constraint
because you say I've got this amount of
time I better knock something out right
now if you're working on a project for a
client or an assignment and you've got a
little bit more time a technique I like
to use is I will build out that project
right so let's say I'm building a
project for one day two three days I
build that project out then if I have
the time I allow myself to step away
from that project give myself a full 24
hours 48 hours is even better and then
come back with fresh eyes on that
project
and have a real good look at that
project because all times we get stuck
in seeing this repetition over and over
as we preview like I don't know how you
are when I preview my work it's looping
over and over and it doesn't stop and
I'm making adjustments as it's looping
and we can get our eyes can you just get
stuck in on that image I think it looks
amazing and we step away for 24-48 hours
and come back we can be like actually
that's not as amazing as I thought it
was I can see with fresh eyes now let me
make an adjustment here so limit your
time on a project these these things of
limiting assets limiting effects and
plugins limiting your time these are
just ways to help you work smarter and
to help you create better motion design
by setting creative constraints and
limits for your projects so that's what
I got for you today hope you guys learn
something new as always I invite you to
check out motion science TV for awesome
tutorials training lessons all good
things until next time I'm Cameron and
this is motion science see ya
[Music]